I'm sure you've noticed that Lando has
feelings for me which makes working
together difficult because I do not feel
the same way about him
I got so much flat with people like was
he really giving them robots because I
don't think Lando would do that I was
like I maybe he would let's say I don't
know but also I stand by him like
there's lots of things to space
[Music]
Wednesday I'm sorry
uh what was the community
I'm locked out of my old kingdom you're
not
see what I'm saying
you're saying I could be a lawyer I'm
saying you're a football player it's in
your blood that's racist your soul
that's racist your eyes that's gay
that's homophobic that's black that's
racist damn my whole career has been
moments that I didn't realize until
afterwards were like special which I
think is exactly how you want them to be
like you don't want to realize that in
community I honed a lot of skills that I
didn't know were like valuable we must
have changed like a sound Cruise like
every I'm not joking like maybe every
six weeks I don't know why like it just
happened that way so I would have to ADR
and I thought you and I would ADR entire
episodes and I thought that was normal
same thing with the Improv thing I
thought that was television I thought
that's just what you did they would be
like yeah and then Donald says something
funny I am the truest repairman and I
was like okay that's like that's
Hollywood so I would just
I would I I I think the first season I
was like really nervous about it but
once I realized like oh you can do this
again and again and again and it'll be
fine it really let me like be loose and
also I was like friends with those guys
so I didn't feel like nervous about like
we were always trying to make each other
laugh but he was like you know Dan's
kind of like a story expert so he really
understands story so sometimes we
wouldn't get the scripts until like the
day of I don't memorize scripts at all
anymore I haven't memorized the script
since Maybe
College like but like now I get the
script like even stuff I write or
whatever I will get it and I'll learn it
in the like makeup chair and then so I
think all that stuff was just I was just
lucky that I thought that's what you had
to do we really appreciate you doing
this sure and three two one Troy and
Abbott in the morning and we're back
look who's here Jeff Winger Jeff how do
you stay so fit
uh diet exercise genetics we had no clue
that like people were watching Community
NBC made it very clear like they're like
this is a bomb this show belongs in the
garbage like they were like I mean like
well it just it wasn't that it was just
like you know we weren't like the cool
show like everybody was like Parks and
Rec has all the cool people we were kind
of like oh I guess we're like kind of
the Misfits and like you know I had
friends on Parkinson Rec and I was like
oh I guess we're just kind of like you
know this silly show like no one kind of
cares about I swear to God it wasn't
until
I got to Canada I did like a show in
Canada and people were like going crazy
like people were walking they were like
oh everybody wanted me to do the
handshake with them it was very intense
like me and me and Danny went out for
dinner
at Pine and crane like I guess a week
ago was wild like I was like people
acted like they would like saw a
Pokemon I didn't realize people
cared that much I mean I guess we went
to Comic Con once and it was a little
crazy like but I was like that's
Comic-Con that's like that's like nerd
Central so like I was expecting people
to like like to like be into it like
that but it is strange now like where
I'm like oh yeah people watch the show
especially now with like it being on
like streaming
you know people watch it in a weekend
not cool not cool not cool not cool hey
buddy hey it's coming back in January
six seasons in a movie six seasons in a
movie Community movie We're supposed to
be there's some progress on and we're
supposed to be shooting it soon I
haven't seen the script don't know I'm a
true Dan fashion we'll probably get it
on the first
day but yeah I mean like
it's supposed to be happening but I know
Justin as much about it as
you do solo
Captain Lindo charism on Seoul
looks like you're having a good day I'm
a lucky guy
can I ask you a question Captain
Calrissian anything hand
but that's okay first black man in space
bro
Lando first black man in space I guess
there's some the Star Trek have any
black people I mean yeah like I guess
Star Trek does that I guess like Star
Trek has like a very Multicultural like
crew which I guess was a big deal back
then but Lando I guess for some reason
like people feel like this is a real
black person in space I don't know why
you might want to buckle up baby
I remember my dad showing me Star Wars
and being like yo this is Lando and he's
you know he feels he also feels pulpey
the rest of those you know the whole
Skywalker family you can't really
with the Canon you can have a a pulpy
kind of like
shitty Lando novel that feels like
outside of the Star Wars universe but
still in it and I think that's why
people like him he's the most elastic of
the of the characters because you don't
know where he's from or who he is or
whatever there's only really those like
three little books so yeah like I was
man that was it was dope to play him it
was really fun the Calrissian Chronicles
chapter five
continued
personally I wasn't all that impressed
with the true room no sense of humor or
style nonetheless their L3 and I were
deep in their sacred Temple and that's
when we saw it
always something I met Billy D right
before I played him I remember that day
really we met at little Doms and he was
like really you know just a funny guy
like he he didn't like we talked about a
bunch of other stuff like I wanted to
know like what it should be like all
that kind of stuff I wanted to really
get into because I really didn't want to
let anybody down and I remember
he was talking about like I was like he
was oh you've been to Kauai man I got
married on Kauai yeah I got married to
the diamond it was like my second one he
was talking about he had all these great
stories but I kept being like yes sir um
sir like what do I do to play and he
literally goes like just be Charming
like he was like just be Charming
you're like that's that's pretty much it
and he's like looking around he's like
that's that's that's that's the secret
like and I was like okay and I guess
he's right like he's kind of like
Lando's like charm incarnate which you
know he's kind of a Maverick which I
don't think there's a lot of anymore
like you know it's hard to be like the
smooth talker nowadays you know because
like where's the line but I think that's
also where the danger is it's like how
close can you get without stripping over
it I mean I would love to I would love
to play Lando again it's a it's a fun
time to be him it just has to be the
right
it just needs to be the right way to do
it I'm all about like now it's like you
know like time is precious I think
everybody like you know in the past
couple of years this pandemic like
really
had people experience time in a way
where they're like well why am I I
should be around oranges like kind of
the people you know like people kind of
realize like their time is valuable you
know you only get so much so like I'm
not interested in doing anything that's
just gonna be like a waste of my time or
just a paycheck I'd much rather like you
know spend time with people that I like
enjoy so it just has to be the right
thing which I think it could be I mean
like Lando is definitely somebody I like
to hang out with so yeah I mean
we're talking about it that's as much as
I can say you know without Kathleen
Kennedy like hunting me down
White Lotus
I'm laughing because you're just like oh
you really do have to say it though
um Atlanta
I know you probably think I'm pretty
responsible but I'm I'm working on
something that I think could be really
big for me and you you know I guess like
you know you just got to be really
specific I think at the end of the day
like we were really trying to portray
like what it felt like to be us
specifically like me and Steven have
like a very like we're brothers so we
had a very common thread but we also
were seeing different parts and like we
we but we always sort of felt like we
were like the whole the whole show was
supposed to feel like whatever like a
little bit because that's how it felt to
us anyway growing up where it was like
oh that happened like and we got to keep
moving whatever like a little bit and I
feel like it we we we we kind of
captured that oh
hey man chill cheers congratulations
[Applause]
but for what
I Choose You
You're My Sacrifice
[Applause]
my brother
has my mother's sense of humor like even
more so than me like I feel like I have
like maybe 60 my dad 40 my mom but he
has like maybe 60 my mom and 40. and
it's a very dark sense of humor there's
like a video of like a guy who had all
of his teeth taken out by the by the
dentist and he's like I'm gonna look
like a freak now oh Mr God he starts
crying and I was like I was like whoa
and I like showed my brother that and my
brother must have left for a week like
like he like literally like he'd be like
and I'd be like what is so funny about
this he was like it's so horrible
like I was like yeah like that's that's
us a little bit where we're like yeah
this this is horrible so it's kind
of funny because all of this is like
unnecessary in the end not to get like
too sardonic or like you know but I I
think that is like our humor is like
this didn't have to happen she said
kidnapping when she called okay
kidnapping serious you know that right
Willie well I must kidnap that in
1974 because she ain't been a kid in
four to five years no and don't go in
there the alligators in there what
but there were a lot of guest
appearances Cree
I love Creed just I just love her and
she's kind of like the blueprint for
like crunchy black kids so like I feel
like I I just I just love her Essence
and she's just like such a a subtle part
of everybody's childhood because she did
all those voices excuse me so she I was
just I was just happy to hang with her
between you and me
still with taken
man look it's good to know that you
it's good to know that you don't hate
black people now you know all right no
no no no no no no I can't stand the hell
out of here well now I feel that way
because he tried to run my career the
Liam Neeson one was like yo shout out to
Jordan Peele we're making that happen yo
shout out I was like yo I have this idea
and I you know obviously Liam was like I
don't know you know like I just don't
you know you know because he felt a lot
of Shame you know he's like I don't he's
like I I he's like I was trying to do
the right thing I was like yeah like and
in the writer's room we had talked about
we're like is that really the message
that we want is like you know when
people actually go out on a limb and go
like I was wrong to like on them we
were like we just thought it was kind of
a funny like thing and also I was like
because the lesson he's gonna learn from
this is like yeah I'm never telling the
truth again so we were like that's
really funny you think we could get him
to do and what I love about that episode
and about him is like that episode
doesn't work without him there is nobody
else like maybe the maybe homie from
Seinfeld yeah like like maybe him being
like that we were like but that's not as
real event and it's not it's not the
same it's like Liam like it it's a
different feeling so we were like we
thought that would work and like shout
out to Jordan peel who actually put us
in contact and shout out to Liam's son
who allowed that to happen so like that
I felt like that was a super iconic
moment
Marshall Johnson
yes
you've been served
I'm sorry what is this about
[Music]
my name is Shaniqua Johnson of the Saint
Louis Johnsons your family owned my
great great grandmother and father for
12 years you owe me money people are
gonna hate this
[Laughter]
what we thought but I think at the
beginning of season three what I we have
a big white board in the writer's room
and at the beginning of season three we
all came back I remember writing down in
front of everybody so we remembered I
was like
do what others cannot I was like we're
the only show that can do this and I was
like that's what's gonna make us special
because by that point like you know
honestly like the thing that I remember
now that was in the back of my head is
like you know remember Rage Against the
Machine like I remember their first two
albums was I was so into them and then
their third one like they kind of like I
see what now what it was like they kind
of went back to like the hip-hop roots
of it but I wasn't I was like I'm not
feeling this as much as nothing and I
remember talking to my dad about it and
he was like well everybody else is kind
of doing the rap rock thing now so like
they have to like be themselves more
and that to differentiate differentiate
themselves and I felt like that's what I
kind of wanted to do like I was like I
just wanted to tell stories at the end
of the day like all of this really is
about like you know stories like I'm
like who can tell the best story who has
the best ideas and I was like yeah like
there are some good it's it's not like
the show Atlanta that people wanted but
it's the point of view of Atlanta and I
I stand by I was like man I think that
might be even after season four which
people were like this is like a perfect
but I'm like season three is I still
think my favorite like I love the Black
and White episode
I love so much about that season because
it doesn't make you feel like it's not a
warm hug it's like it's the feeling of
your friend who's never left Atlanta
going to like San Francisco or Paris and
being like I like it back in Atlanta
like it's like I want to go back home
like that is the feeling and I think a
lot of people reacted that way they were
like where's Atlanta I want to go back
home there's a great story like uh Chief
Keef going to like Paris recording with
Kanye and and the whole time he was like
this ain't it
he's like this ain't it and I'm like
yeah like that is why you are the way
you are because you are so tied to your
home but when you come back those
chicken wings don't taste the same
because you've experienced something
else like my brother always be like
crickets is the and then when he
comes back it's like these taste
different like yeah you experienced
something else so I'm like yeah that's
probably why people like season four a
lot more because it's like yeah you're
back home but you've kind of outgrown it
Childish Gambino
Alison Brie introduced me to Ludwig
Ludwig was doing the music on community
I remember very it was weird like you
know it was almost like a like love at
first sight type moment where I remember
he was in the food trailer and she's
like Donald you got to meet Ludwig and
he was wearing like purple pants and he
was like cutting a green apple and he
goes hey how are you oh cool he's like I
do the music cool and I was like I'm
working on this kind of music thing we
should meet up and it was very I mean it
was very organic I don't know why that
happened honestly like it just I don't I
mean like on most shows you don't
usually meet the composer it's like it
just doesn't happen like you're not like
on in most movies you're not meeting the
composer so like he just happened to be
around and I think we were both just
interested I was like I love music I was
like oh cool like you should take a look
at my music it's just a lesson to people
where I'm like yeah like it's not about
like chasing opportunity it's like don't
be afraid of like yourself I feel like
if I was like oh so no one should listen
to this music I was like no you should
I was like you should check this out I
want to know what you think and that's
kind of what happened and then like you
know we just have really really me and
Ludwig have like amazing chemistry I
don't like that's the only way I can put
it like he's like such a weirdo in the
best sense
[Music]
I wish you guys could hear the first
version of Redbone it was so weird like
it was such a weird I was actually
listening to it the other day I was like
what a weird song this was and then we
like cleaned it and we're like oh
yeah this is America
[Music]
let's just be real like we did you know
time is the oven that makes something
special but we did a lot of work I had
that idea like three years before and I
told hero the idea he's like man I
really he's like I want to do that like
I really want to do that and I was like
cool and I had the song and I swear to
God like it was started as a the idea
for the song Started as a joke to be
completely honest like this is America
like that was all we had was like that
line this is America
and it started as a drake diss to be
honest it's like I was like as it was
like a funny way of like doing it but
then I was like this sounds kind of
hard though you know so I was like let
me play with it so we just had that for
a long time I told hero the idea and he
was like oh let's let's do it and
honestly we studied Thriller for a long
time because I was like how do you make
something how do you make people care
about anything anymore there's just so
much well you have to have a moment
in real time which was like SNL which
like fam and Chad well from Rothstein
like we're like okay we're gonna do this
SNL thing we'll drop it at midnight also
like the feeling of like what was
happening at the time I was like oh
that's it informed like because you know
of all the uprisings and rides that were
happening like it really informed like
my writing and stuff and then I was like
oh I really you know I was like having
sessions with like you know Thug and all
these people and I was like hey would
you want get on that I was like you know
like making it like a We are the world
like for trap I was like that just it
just became something where I was like
yo it needs to feel like all of it to me
culture is just compression of
information so I was like all of it just
needs to be compressed into this moment
so what was happening needed to feel
like it could only be happening right
now we shot it on film that was
deliberate like we were like oh two
takes like kind of literally one shot
like we were like let's just do it like
to because it's really three shots it's
like that first half that second half
and then the running we were like I
needed to feel continuous because I
needed to feel like a moment because
moments I feel like the internet kind of
robs moments so I that was really the
work that we put in I was I feel very
it's interesting that it worked I didn't
we were like oh I mean it probably
wasn't going to work but we really just
studied Thriller a lot we studied how
that became iconic and I was like oh
well you know you have to do some a lot
of things the first time and I was like
but Thriller was like a big important
part you know you know who I did a lot
of research on that people don't
probably think I did but I actually
watched his moves a lot to make sure I
didn't do the exact same thing was like
Robbie Williams I actually watched him a
lot because like I saw him get a lot of
hate and he's not necessarily an actor
actor but like you know mostly
multi-disciplinary like people
you know I I call it a vent you need a
vent you need some steam to like let
something off
because people like
you know
Stevie wondered amazing genius but
people like but he's blind so that's the
vent you know like same thing with
Prince he's like oh but he's short
like I was like oh buddy like there's
something where you know you don't want
you want to give people a vent to be
able to and I knew that wasn't gonna be
easy but I also was like
but also I think that gener there's an
older generation I think a lot of things
have changed because uh
the you used it used to be about access
so it'd be like if you had access to be
able to make stuff and then you happen
to be good it was different now everyone
has access so and it's way easier to
make all these things it's way easier to
make music you know it's it's we're
we're always racing towards very good
ideas that's all it matters at the end
of the day and I think the idea of like
this person not being great at other
stuff is an old idea of just like yeah
Elvis couldn't be a great necessarily
actor necessarily because he was
focusing so much it it making music took
a lot more but now it's like all that
stuff is happening all those things are
the same anyway so I feel like yeah like
somebody had to do it and it wasn't like
I was like I'm the one to do it I think
I honestly just I didn't want to stop
doing that other stuff it was like way
too much fun and I I had learned like yo
if you're like living for other people
you're probably gonna end up being sad
which is like what's the point